I think that the you know the moment of
the birth of the vampire myth in English
literature is with essentially there is
a few writings here and there
appointment isn't that but in fiction
most everyone agrees that is is Berthoud
by john w Polidori and with the short
story the vampire now the fact that
Polidori had an ambivalent relationship
with his master and friend lord byron
and he baised the character of the main
vampire in that story Lord Ruthven on
North Byron you know immediately gave
birth to a vampire that was both a loads
from parasite and a dandy a seductive
character that is later absorbed by
Stoker in Dracula and you know you can
trace it all the way to one rise and and
I think that right now we are we're we
have an unbridled sort of melodramatic
romantic fantasy with the vampire is
only one half of the myth the bad-boy
romantic lead myth which is essential in
gothic fiction you know it can be
Heathcliff and withering Heights or it
can be Robert Pattinson in to highlight
the thing that that it tells you right
now is that human relationships intimate
relationships have become so completely
demystified they have become so prosaic
you know where you whenever you talk
about a relationship you're talking
about it in in very prosaic terms how
much does he or she make what job
security nest nest egg planning it's all
very materialistic double/double income
household it all becomes very frisée ik
and it's almost impossible to dream
romantic things without sounding corny
so you know or the fascination of
romantic fiction with the bad boy gets
sublimated and and dark angels are
created angels of the night that create
a spiritual and physical bond with with
the love interest that is permanent and
eternal
so through that fiction you can abandon
yourself to to the law of a romantic
fantasy without feeling silly or stupid
what I find symptomatic is that I think
for them I daresay for the first time in
the culture of mankind the vampire has
been sort of defang by making them
celibate and asexual as opposed to poly
poly sexual like Anne Rice did them they
have been been they have in Mormon eyes
so to speak into sin into being a
sanitized creature and you know I'm not
in favor or against it I'm fascinated by
it because I do think it's a very strong
symbol of where we are and I find it
intriguing and I try to to watch the
phenomenon without without judging it
but it is quite peculiar
what we were trying to do though is we
were trying to deal with aspects with
the only sensuality in the strain books
is is the sensuality of feeding that
pleases the predator but doesn't please
the prey